Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman Show,
I'm Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire, I'll be
sitting in for David all of this week. And if by
chance you want more from me, you can find me on
YouTube at youtube.com slash fair and balanced and
of course, YouTube dot com slash the Ring of Fire.
One of the biggest stories that is still
happening this week as more and more new
information continues to trickle out every couple
of hours. Honestly, at this point is Joe Manchin.
The biggest, baddest bad guy in
the country today, Joe Manchin.
And on Monday, the Huffington Post reported
that Joe Manchin has allegedly, according
to two insiders that Huffington Post spoke to.
Manchin has been telling his Democratic colleagues
that one of the main reasons he is objecting to
extending the child tax credit that is lifted
30 percent of children in this country out of
poverty. Is because if you give poor people money,
they're just going to spend it on drugs.
Now there is no audio, at least not that I've
seen or has been reported on of Joe Manchin saying
these things. So let's mention that right off the
bat, this is coming from two insiders who spoke
to the Huffington Post. They said this is what
Manchin has been telling people behind the scenes.
This is his talking point. If you give poor people
money, they're going to spend it on drugs. So
we have to assume at the moment, or at least
for the sake of this segment here, we're going
to assume what they're saying is accurate again,
without a recording of this, without it written
down, Joe Manchin writing it himself. We can't
say for certain that Joe Manchin did say this,
so let's imagine that he did OK. Let's imagine
for a moment that Joe Manchin used this tired,
worn out, Republican talking point. To trash
the extended child tax credit, which again
has lifted 30 percent of children in this country
out of poverty. 30 percent. This child tax credit
that's been going out for most of this year has
fundamentally changed the lives of millions of
Americans. But it has become one of Joe Mansion's
biggest targets in the build back better bill.
And is it really because he honestly thinks
that poor people, if they get cash in hand,
they're just going to buy drugs? Is that
really what he believes? Does he honestly think
that every poor person in this country,
everybody living in poverty is just on drugs?
Is that what he thinks the cause of poverty
and suffering is here in the United States,
it's only because of drugs. If somebody is living
in poverty, that in no way makes them more likely
to do drugs here in the United States. Poverty
is not a manifestation that comes from addiction.
And it's absolutely. Embarrassing
and irresponsible for anyone left or
right to make that claim. And if this is
in fact, how Joe Manchin feels, if he did
really say this to his Democratic colleagues,
which I would love if any one of them would come
forward and say yes, Manchin told me this.
Let's confirm it. So if this did happen?
I believe at this point, the Democratic Party
would have no choice but to kick Joe Manchin out.
And I believe that they should I believe
they should kick him off of his committees.
I believe that they should refuse to
give him any funding from the party.
Not just based on this statement, either,
by the way. Based on the fact that he is
obstructing the Democrats own agenda. You
know, Bernie Sanders pointed out last week
in an interview with Chris Hayes on MSNBC that
Manchin and cinema were acting like Republicans.
And when you look at what Republicans have done
this year. Nothing but obstruction, obstruct,
obstruct, obstruct, especially in the Senate.
But then when you look at mansion in cinema.
Obstruct, obstruct, obstruct. So it is
as if they were acting like Republicans,
not as if they are. That is what this is, Joe
Manchin understands what build back better
could do to residents of West Virginia.
They're not happy with him, by the way.
The story's been pouring in ever since
his appearance on Fox News on Sunday
about West Virginia residents unhappy that
Joe Manchin is standing in the way of this.
But it all comes down at the moment to that
child tax credit. You know, last week, Manchin
was confronted by reporters asking, Why do you
oppose the child tax credit? He said it was B.S.,
your B.S.. This isn't true. I never said that. I
never did that. But I think it was October 21st
is when the news reports came out saying that Joe
Manchin wants to cut down the child tax credit
wants to put a cap on it. You know, if you make
over 60000 a year, you don't get anything at all.
So he wanted to lower the cap that was reported
back then. He didn't call those reports B.S..
So he's lying. He's lying to us, he's lying to his
constituents, he's lying to the country about what
he actually is trying to do. And again, if this
Huffington Post report is accurate and again,
we cannot say for certain that it happened, but
if this report is accurate. Then he is basing his
rationale for killing the extended child tax
credit. On faulty and fraudulent information.
And that is unacceptable considering how much this
bill would benefit the American public. It's not
going to lead to inflation. It's not going to lead
to expanded drug use here in the United States.
It would help continue to lift people
out of poverty. It would help people
be able to afford their bills. It would
help people have a way, a stepping stone
to creating a better life, that is what this
piece of legislation would do. Build back better.
Is literally right there in the name, folks. But
Joe Manchin doesn't think you should have it.
Because Joe Manchin thinks
you're going to go buy drugs.
Absolutely sickening that this sitting
Democratic member of the United States Senate
would result to Republican talking points
going all the way back, by the way, to Ronald
Reagan. All right, the welfare queens, the people
living high on the government hog while the rest
of you, hardworking folks are out there working
your fingers to the bone, but they're getting the
free government money, not having to do anything.
That's what this is. This is a continuation
of the fraudulent welfare queen trope pushed
by Republicans in the 80s and of course,
ever since then, not to mention the fact, you
know, just based on statistics. We know that means
testing. And, of course, drug testing. Welfare
recipients, government assistance recipients
yields very little results. In fact, from 2011 to
2017, you had multiple states across the country
enact some kind of drug testing in order
to receive social welfare programs.
One percent, one percent. Of the applicants
who were tested tested positive for drugs,
one percent. Over a six year period. So that
alone kills Joe Manchin is talking point
helps kill that age old
Republican talking point to.
But apparently that wasn't enough, it didn't stop
Joe Manchin from allegedly telling his colleagues
that if you give poor people more money.
They're just going to go spend it on drugs.